there's a lot more to Wang than meets
the eye even the mystical third eye far
from a simple magician's assistant he's
been an orphan a lover and even a doctor
himself join us as we break down the
history of the most loyal sidekick of
the sorcerer supreme one was introduced
alongside Doctor Strange in 1963 strange
tales issue 110 the duo is strikingly
creepy in their first comic book outing
not evil exactly but menacing to behold
and always draped in shadow strange is
explicitly aligned with black magic and
this Greenwich Village lair is creepy a
murky one first appears when he opens a
front door strangest sanctum to a young
man in search of strangers friend of
help inviting the guest in with the odd
declaration of a Doctor Strange nose all
one wasn't a character early on so much
as a piece of said dressing he guided
people to strange his office wore
whatever the artist thought looked
foreign enough and served as a visual
reminder of strangest ties to the
mysterious knowledge of Asia as was
unfortunately common at the time this
amounted to whatever mumbo-jumbo the
rites of thought sounded convincing
it wasn't until strange tales issue 119
that the character even got a name and
you are Wow Wow just one like Adele
things would change as a decades well
done however and readers samandar better
representation and more complex stories
one's ancestors have served the masters
of the mystic arts for untold
generations with the family having a
close relationship to the ancient one in
particular one was still a baby when he
was first presented to the ancient one
and was swiftly sent to ensconce himself
in studies of the arcane wonk is
particularly tied to a figure named Khan
his ancestor who lived 1,000 years ago a
student of magic and a brilliant warrior
Khan was the first to dedicate himself
to the ancient one given that one serves
strange and not the ancient one he is
the first to break this tradition since
the ancient one commanded this it's not
exactly a transgression but it does
highlight one significance he's the
first person in his family to break
course in centuries though Wong might
come from a long line of warrior monks a
single early devoted to their duty he's
made time for the ladies over the years
chief among them is MH Aang
his betrothed years passed from the time
when they were first engaged during
which they knew they were promised to
each other but were too young to Wed
years in which Wang went on many
life-changing adventures and met many
fascinating women
Sarah wolf or strangers secretary was a
particular temptation an attraction
grows between her and one that he puts
her reluctance stop to for the sake of
its relationship with EMA though he's
far from a disloyal lover
he's definitely sort of a man about town
town here meaning the entire cosmos and
parts are known he's got a certain
Janice a choir the ladies of every
dimension simply can't deny superhero
problem number one is protecting those
close to you and no one's been around
dr. strange longer than Wong naturally
this means that Wong has gotten
kidnapped a lot there's the time in the
1970s and the shadow queen captured him
and put him in a dungeon there's the
time in the 80s with a throne er an
alien body abducted Wong along with
strangers entire house this has happened
what feels like dozens of times the
bottom line is he gets taken captive a
lot but in the modern day he tends to
fight back more gone is the Wong who
must be held in mystical stasis for his
own protection estranged so often
insisted upon back in the silver and
bronze age stories they starred in here
to stay is the one who gives as good as
he gets
generally speaking where dr. strange
goes so goes Wong but they haven't
always gotten along more than once a
strange and wonderful announced and at
times have come close to ending their
partnership altogether in the mid-1990s
dr. strange a sorcerer supreme told a
story in which a demon named as a us and
the evil sorceress Salome turned one
against his friend and master the two
villains were able to pull off this act
of trickery due to a very real tension
between strange and Wong over the
doctor's failure to protect email from
being killed they use the prospect of
resurrecting he made to manipulate Wong
to try and kill strained on their behalf
though the two ended up reconciling it
was a moment of truly broken trust
between the duo that took some time to
repair but ultimately made their
relationship stronger Wong has been
around long enough to have faced a
pantheon of foes cosmic abominations
check murderous Sorceress's been there
done that but in the 2007 miniseries
Doctor Strange the oath one faced down a
truly formidable villain cancer at first
he tried to hide his diagnosis from
strange until it found someone to take
his place at a sorcerer aside but
strange still discovered the truth the
dude is a doctor after all heartbroken
at the prospect of losing his oldest and
most trusted friend strange embarks on a
desperate frantic quest to save him he
succeeded in curing him but Wong's
courage in the face of seemingly certain
death proved his fealty to strange as
well as their mission of
service to the greater good there's no
corner of the Marvel Universe more well
strange than the one Wong occupies and
the best Doctor Strange creative team to
lead into the mysticism of it all
there's a comic series that doesn't have
to play by the rules of super heroics if
our world is magical and it follows its
own rules it's funny then that by and
large Wong is not himself a magic user
this is very much not the case in the
movies where Wong wheeled sigils and
Scrolls were the best of them but on the
page with the exception of a few
alternate universe interpretations and
special circumstances mungus merely a
peek martial artist he's comfortable
with the spells and sayings of the world
strange occupies but he does not use
them himself he stands in contrast to
the magic around him and the search acts
as a stable pillar in a shifting a
mystical world we imagining for the
bread and butter of superhero comics
that Doctor Strange and Wong have been
surprisingly absent from Marvel's many
alternate takes except for the time that
one was inspired by Doctor Strange to
become a doctor himself in the 2004
limited series strange Wong Gus
reimagined as a Tibetan orphan who had
the good luck to be saved by Stephen
strange then a young medical student
inspired by strangers act of kindness
one goes on to become an American doctor
operating under the name Stephen Wong he
becomes a warrior and the sorcerer in
his own right despite all of this one
ultimately still manages to become
stranger servants though the story
treats this development as a complicated
one it's a powerful boundary breaking
story that asks the question who should
be servants and who should be masters
it's up to the reader to the side check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos but your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
you